okay so then we get to the main message
of joe biden's
quasi victory speech and i keep saying
quasi victory speech because he hasn't
won anything yet right guys there's
still a legal process i know cnn called
something
but who cares who cares doesn't say in
the constitution and when wolf blitzer
says a thing it magically becomes true
anyway joe biden gave his his speech in
wilmington delaware 70 feet from his
basement
and uh and he explained that it was time
to put away harsh rhetoric
says captain i'll put you all back in
chains and you ain't black if you don't
vote for joe biden
time to put away harsh rhetoric is it
here's joe biden
it's time to put away the harsh rhetoric
lower the temperature see each other
again
listen to each other again and to make
progress
we have to stop treating our opponents
as our enemies
they are not our enemies they are
americans the bible tells us
to everything there is a season a time
to build
a time to reap and a time to sow and a
time to heal
this is the time to heal in america it's
a time to heal guys
right it's time to heal so here's the
question you should be asking yourself
what kind of healing are we talking
about
joe are we talking about the kind of
healing where you acknowledge there are
people who disagree with you
and then we all decide to live together
and leave each other alone because
that's my kind of healing right i like
the kind of healing where california
gets to be as dumb as california wants
to be and florida gets to be as awesome
as florida gets to be
and if you're religious you get to be
religious and if you're secular you get
to be secular and nobody puts
their values on somebody else's back
right that that's kind of
honestly that's my kind of living
together is where we have certain core
values like the protection of human life
right like the free like freedom of
speech freedom of the press like the
ones that are in the constitution mainly
and then we mostly leave each other
alone
or the values of the declaration of
independence we agree on that and then
we agree to go our separate ways and we
still have a community because we are
connected by these basic ideas that's my
idea
of healing i don't think that's what joe
biden means by healing i think what joe
biden means by healing is here's my
democratic party agenda and if you
disagree with it you're not part of the
healing why aren't you part of the
healing i'm going to clock in the head
unless you're part of the healing
heal with me heal right i i don't think
this is going to be
an era of tolerance the fight is just
beginning we'll see this in just one
second when you see what the democratic
party who is not joe biden
is actually saying while joe biden is
out there putting a nice friendly
potemkin village facade on what is a
seething undercurrent
of rage inside the democratic party okay
so then joe biden talks about his
mandate this
i think this is my favorite part of joe
biden's little speech is where he talked
about
his uh his mandate as president it turns
out his mandate as president
is really i mean it just
that's the only way to describe it
because it means nothing it's
meaningless
it's meaningless slogans actually turns
out his mandate isn't for our tax
increase
his mandate is not for the green new
deal his mandate is not
for any of his major policy
prescriptions joe biden himself
expresses it his mandate is to be a nice
man
which wow what a mandate big thing's
gonna happen because joe biden is a nice
old man
here's grandpa joe what is our mandate
i believe it's this americans have
called upon us
to marshal the forces of decency the
forces of fairness
to marshall the forces of science and
the forces of hope
and the great battles of our time the
battle of control the virus
the battle to build prosperity the
battle to secure
your family's health care the battle
will achieve racial justice
and root out systemic racism in this
country and the battle
to save our planet by getting climate
under control
the battle restored decency defend
democracy
and gave everybody in this country a
fair shot
you got that that's a strong mandate
right there that's a strong mandate for
decency mcferron as mcscience mchopey
right strong agenda right there science
mchopey mcferrin's decency face
wow wow what a strong mandate not for a
specific agenda
mind you but to be a nice guy who cares
about things
not what what things any things like the
things like science and decency and
democracy and hope
and massages of random women and
smelling that like lots of lots of
things like there's a mandate guys
okay now what's hilarious about that of
course is that he just says i want a
historic election
i won a historic election and now i have
a mandate a mandate to a hexagon family
name trump allows if you will okay all
right fine that doesn't seem like a very
strong mandate but
sure go with it okay and then he pledges
again we're gonna end the era of
demonization
we're gonna end the era of demonization
again you know i don't even need to play
more jobs it's the same message over and
over
right i'm going to work as hard for
everybody as people if you didn't vote
for me i'm going to work hard for you
and we're going to get together and
we're going to be best friends again
we're going to play disco it's going to
be amazing guys
it's gonna we're gonna cure disease like
cancer and alzheimer's all right he said
that he's gonna cure cancer and
alzheimer's he's looking ahead to an
america that's freer and more just
that creates jobs with dignity and
respect and that cures diseases like
cancer and alzheimer's by the way
i will note a piece of odd timing pfizer
today today
announced that they have developed a
vaccine that is 90
effective at preventing coronavirus
infections they announced it today
weird timing and they wait until after
the weekend
when uh the media announced that joe
biden is president and then magically
just like the clouds parting pfizer
announces this count me slightly
suspicious like it's great news
but let me just point something out
donald trump was president when pfizer
got the money to develop that vaccine
that's a trump administration
accomplishment that is not a joe biden
accomplishment anyway
okay so that is the message of joe biden
right is that he has a mandate for
niceness and happiness and fairness and
brotherhood
and smoking dope and hanging out and
watching the moon rise and all that kind
of stuff right
it's gonna be hoping to change face part
two except weird and old and white
that's good it's gonna be fantastic okay
then there is
then there's the democratic party and
let me just say when they say unity i
don't think that they mean that we get
together and we sing kumbaya
i think they mean unity like here's a
re-education camp
would you like to come this way then we
can be unified afterward
like fahrenheit 451 reunification
what if we could be unified because you
think like me
right so if joe biden wants to wants to
actually promote unity seriously this is
a serious thing now
if joe biden wants to promote unity at
some point he has to speak to his own
side
here's the thing in any relationship if
you want
there to be any sort of comedy between
people
you have to go to the people who are
creating the vision on your own side and
tell them to knock it off
you have to have a sister soldier moment
bill clinton famously did this in 1992
there was a a very little-known rapper
named sister soldier who said something
racially terrible about conflict between
the races
and clinton chided her right this was a
big moment he kind of picked her out of
a hat and went after her specifically in
order to have this
unity moment there were some of us
throughout the trump administration
who loved what trump was doing but we
were not super happy with a lot of the
divisive things that trump was saying
and we would call that out right
i've not seen one iota of that from the
democrats not one iota
not one okay like i'll believe that joe
biden wants unity when he says to
michelle obama knock it off
because here's what michelle obama
tweeted over the weekend right the heart
and soul of the democratic party she had
an instagram post
and here's what she put out in her
instagram post
voting in one election isn't a magic
wand and neither is winning one let's
remember
that tens of millions of people voted
for the status quo
even when it meant supporting lies hate
chaos and division
does that sound like a kumbaya message
to you does that sound like
she wants to understand people on the
other side or like she cares about
people on the other side
does that sound like michelle obama who
is in fact the oprah winfrey of the
democratic party right she is this
this mom of the democratic party who are
all supposed to respect her opinion
because she's so nice and wonderful
and and she's become she's moved from
being sort of a divisive figure in her
early iteration to this great unifying
figure the best-selling author in the
united states for the past several years
she literally says that tens of millions
of americans
are motivated by hate and division and
chaos to maintain the status quo
when is joe biden gonna say listen
michelle we need to have unity stop
saying that about your fellow americans
stop it right just stop it stop implying
that people
not implying saying openly that people
who disagree with you are motivated by a
willingness to ignore
hatred and brutality and evil and
nastiness just to maintain the status
quo
you think joe biden's going to say any
of that of course jobin's not going to
say any of that because his own base is
clamoring for blood
they are obeying for political blood at
this point
i got jennifer rubin who used to be
labeled the conservative
voice over at the washington post which
is hilarious so jennifer rubin went on
msnbc
after the media declared joe biden
victorious and again there's a legal
process he's not in fact the
president-elect of the united states
yeah legally speaking
jennifer rubin went on there and she
turned into
fesic from princess bride they put her
in a holocaust cloak lit it on fire and
she starts going
there will be no survivors
here is jennifer rubin going completely
hog wild
it's not only that trump has to lose but
that all his enablers have to lose
they have to we have to collectively in
essence burn down the republican party
um we have to level them because if
there are survivors
if there are people who weather this
storm they will do it again they will
take this as confirmation that hey
it just pays to ride the waves look at
me i've made it through
and so up and down the ticket federal
state local offices the country has to
repudiate this
okay so there will be no survivors guys
there can't be survivors we need to take
a list and check it twice and then
murder everyone at
it like does that sound like unity to
you
joe biden's out there i like unity and
mashed potatoes
and then you got over here michelle
obama going half the country is
motivated by hate and chaos and division
and then you got jennifer rubin out here
going there are more free
no survivor aoc did the same thing
aoc i'm sorry i keep calling her aoc i
keep forgetting
it is sexist and mean to call her by her
twitter handle
aoc instead she's the honorable
representative alexandra ocasio-cortez d
twitch okay she tweeted out is anyone
archiving these trump sycophants for
when they try to downplay or deny their
complicity in the future
i foresee decent probability of many
deleted tweets writings
photos in the future she's keeping a
list right we gotta keep a list of their
bad tweets
of when they support trump lol at the
party of personal responsibility like
being upset at the idea of being
responsible for their behavior over the
last four years
right this is a call for revenge anybody
who supported trump at any point
must be revenged upon vengeance
hey elizabeth abrams who is a former
buddha judge campaign staffer
she tweeted out we're launching the
trump accountability project to make
sure anyone who took a paycheck to help
trump undermine america
is held responsible for what they did
join us and help spread the word
blacklists
this sounds like a party that's looking
for unification and healing
that like debatification right they're
looking for
unity through debuffication because you
understand trump with saddam hussein
and getting rid of trump that means that
anybody who ever liked trump or voted
for him
the 70 million americans voted for trump
70 million americans voted for donald
trump you know who is the second
largest ballot winner in the history of
the united states right now by popular
vote count
donald trump he's won more votes than
barack obama ever did
okay some of that is due to population
growth some of that is because lots and
lots of people
voted for donald trump okay so you're
talking about 70 million
debatfification of 70 million americans
but but unity guys unity
peter beinart who is the uh the
representative of hamas
he tweeted out in the 1990s i came to
know many young conservative journalists
now some are household names back then i
never imagined a moral test that would
so vividly expose their characters
some abetted tyranny others resisted it
trump x-rayed their souls i'll never
forget what i saw well i mean if peter
beinart
who still makes excuses for hamas
terrorists is saying that he is x-rayed
souls then i guess that we'll have to
take him
at his word yes i see i foresee an era
of healing
and national unity or alternatively i
see an era in which
joe biden is driven by the left in his
party
to wage war upon all the values that
many americans hold dear especially in
election where americans
rejected the progressive left understand
this is an election where americans
looked at the project
at the progressive left and they vomited
on it even in california they rejected
a couple of very progressive measures
right there was one measure that was
going to kill uber and lyft they killed
it there was a measure that was going to
reinstall affirmative action in the
constitution of the state of california
essentially they rejected it
overwhelmingly
all across the country radicals were
rejected the democratic party was handed
a loss in the house
in a year where their top ballot getter
won a record number of votes
more votes than any other candidate in
the history of the republic and they
lost seats in the house
they picked up two seats in the senate
and lost one in alabama
okay that is not a victorious party the
democrats who are calling for healing
and reunification through
demathification
good luck with that good luck the battle
has just begun
again this is not a time of
reunification and healing hey i wish it
were
any seriously i do i wish that joe biden
would say to his own left guys you need
to cut it out
so you guys need to stop this we still
have certain values in common let me
spell them out for you and they do not
involve
using the power of the government gun to
compel my political opponents
to do things that are against their
constitutional rights wouldn't that be
nice but he ain't gonna do that and you
all know he ain't gonna do that
all this happy talk is just all it is
is just pasting a sticker over a gaping
wound in the body politic and we all
know it we all know it
and you can see it in real time i hope
you enjoyed that clip from the ben
shapiro show if you did go ahead and hit
the subscribe button so you stay up to
date on all of our future content